Gisele Pelicot is a hero she fought to make her assaults public
she wanted the public to look at it straight in the eyes
I love this shame she said
must change sides from the victims to the perpetrator
if you're unaware of this Frenchwoman's story
and the trial that's been ongoing in France
her husband for years drugged her and assaulted her
and then invited over 50 men to come over and do the same
and he filmed them and she fought to have these videos and photos
shown to everyone in the courtroom
so that the perpetrators would have to sit and shame
while everyone watched what they did
I can't begin to fathom what she has gone through
and what she continues to go through
and then to take it a step further
that through all of this she's still thinking of others
like has used this as an opportunity
as she said that to show the world that we can shift shame from
from the victims to the perpetrators
as it should be she is my hero